it's 6:30 in the morning
and Kristen is wheeling her prostate
patient into the o.r she's a resident a
surgeon in training it's her job to
learn today she's really hoping to do
some of the nerve sparing extremely
delicate to section that can preserve a
reptile function that'll be up to the
attending surgeon though but he's not
there yet
she and the team put the patient under
and she leads the initial 8 inch
incision in the lower abdomen once she's
got that clamped back she tells the
nurse to call the attending he arrives
gowns up and from there on in their four
hands are mostly in that patient with
him guiding but Kristen leading the way
when the prostates out and yes he let
Kristen do a little nerve sparing he
rips off his scrubs he starts to do
paperwork Kristen Kristen closes the
patient by 8:15 with a junior resident
looking over her shoulder and she lets
him do the final line of sutures Kristen
feels great patients gonna be fine and
no doubt she's a better surgeon than she
was at 6:30 now this is extreme work but
Kristen's learning to do her job the way
that most of us do watching an expert
for a bit getting involved in easy safe
parts of the work and progressing to
riskier and harder tasks as they guide
and decide she's ready my whole life
I've been fascinated by this kind of
learning it feels elemental part of what
makes us human it has different names
apprenticeship coaching mentorship
on-the-job training in surgery it's
called see one do one teach one but the
process is the same and it's been the
main path to skill around the globe
for thousands of years right now we're
handling AI in a way that blocks that
path we're sacrificing learning in our
quest for productivity
I found this first in surgery while I
was at MIT but now I've got evidence
it's happening all over in very
different industries and with very
different kinds of AI if we do nothing
about this millions of us are going to
hit a brick wall as we try to learn to
deal with AI let's go back to surgery to
see how fast forward six months it's
6:30 a.m. again and Kristin is wheeling
another prostate patient in but this
time to the robotic or the attending
leads attaching a four-armed
thousand-pound robot to the patient they
both rip off their scrubs head to
control consoles 10 or 15 feet away and
Kristin just watches the robot allows
the attending to do the whole procedure
himself so he basically does he knows
she needs practice he wants to give her
control but he also knows she'd be
slower and make more mistakes and his
patient comes first so Kristin has no
hope of getting anywhere near those
nerves during this rotation she'll be
lucky if she operates more than 15
minutes during a four-hour procedure and
she knows that when she slips up he'll
tap a touch screen and she'll be
watching again feeling like a kid in the
corner with a dunce cap like all the
studies of robots and work I've done in
the last eight years I started this one
with a big open question how do we learn
to work with intelligent machines to
find out I spent two and a half years
observing dozens of residents and
surgeons doing traditional and robotic
surgery interviewing them and in general
hanging out with the residents as they
tried to learn I covered 18 of the top
u.s. teaching hospitals and the story
was the same most residents were in
Kristin's shoes they got to see one
plenty
but the do one was barely available so
they couldn't struggle and they weren't
learning this was important news for
surgeons but I needed to know how
widespread it was where else was using
AI blockin learning on the job to find
out I've connected with the small but
growing group of young researchers
who've done boots-on-the-ground studies
of work involving AI in very diverse
settings like startups policing
investment banking and online education
like me they spent at least a year and
many hundreds of hours observing
interviewing and often working side by
side with the people they studied we
shared data and I looked for patterns
no matter the industry the work the AI
the story was the same organizations
were trying harder and harder to get
results from AI and they were peeling
learners away from expert work as they
did it start-up managers we're
outsourcing their customer contact cops
had to learn to deal with crime
forecasts without expert support junior
bankers were getting cut out of complex
analysis and professors had to build
online courses without health and the
effect of all of this was the same as in
surgery learning on the job was getting
much harder this can't last McKinsey
estimates that between half a billion
and a billion of us are going to have to
adapt to AI in our daily work by 2030
and we're assuming that on-the-job
learning will be there for us as we try
Accenture slate Asst worker survey
showed that most workers learned key
skills on the job not in formal training
so while we talk a lot about its
potential future impact the aspect of AI
that may matter most right now is that
we're handling it in a way that blocks
learning on the job just when we need it
most now across all our sites a small
minority found a way to learn they did
it by breaking and bending rules
approved methods weren't working so they
bent and broke rules to get hands-on
practice with experts in my setting
residents got involved in robotic
surgery in medical school at the expense
of their generalist education and they
spent hundreds of extra hours with
simulators and recordings of surgery
when you were supposed to learn in the
o.r and maybe most importantly they
found ways to struggle in live
procedures with limited expert
supervision I call all this shadow
learning because it bends the rules and
learners do it out of the limelight and
everyone turns a blind eye because it
gets results remember these are the star
pupils of the bunch now obviously this
is not okay and it's not sustainable
no one should have to risk getting fired
to learn the skills they need to do
their job but we do need to learn from
these people they took serious risks to
learn they understood they needed to
protect struggle and challenge in their
work so that they could push themselves
to tackle hard problems right near the
edge of their capacity they also made
sure there was an expert nearby to offer
pointers and to backstop against
catastrophe let's build this combination
of struggle and expert support into each
AI implementation here's one clear
example I could get of this on the
ground before robots if you were a bomb
disposal technician you dealt with an
AED by walking up to it a junior officer
was hundreds of feet away so could only
watch and help if you decided it was
safe and invited them downrange now you
sit side by side in a bomb-proof truck
you both watch the video feed they
control a distant robot and you guide
the work out loud trainees learn better
than they did before robots we can scale
this to surgery startups policing
investment banking online education and
beyond the good news is we've got new
tools to do it
the Internet and the cloud mean we don't
always need one expert for every trainee
for them to be physically near each
other or even to be in the same
organization and we can build AI to help
to coach learners as they struggle to
coach experts as they coach and to
connect those two groups in smart ways
there are people at work on systems like
this but they've been mostly focused on
formal training and the deeper crisis is
an on-the-job learning we must do better
today's problems demand we do better to
create work that takes full advantage of
a eyes amazing capabilities while
enhancing our skills as we do it that's
the kind of future I dreamed of as a kid
and the time to create it is now thank
you
[Applause]